hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show my little movie review uh
thing that i have going here if you hear
some weird noise in the background
like right now
uh we're having very very strange winter
weather here in florida and it's really
windy and it's kind of raining off and
on so if you hear anything like over
there that's what it is because i'm up
on the second floor and for whatever
reason
i get like all this every time the wind
blows it's like this really it sounds
like a [ __ ] horror movie out there so
that's what it is but you know it's kind
of like adding to the whole atmosphere i
guess
so the movie that we're talking about
today this is kind of like this is for
sure a really forgotten movie in fact so
forgotten that i had actually never
heard of it in my whole entire life
uh even though i really like this era of
film
i actually heard of this when i was
watching a couple weeks ago or actually
like a week or yeah just a week ago i
watched there's an excellent uh
documentary i've brought it up on a
couple of our shows previously and
shutter just added it and it's called uh
woodlands dark and days bewitched a
history of folk horror and it's about
three hours and 15 minutes long and it's
excellent so if you have shutter i
really do recommend it now so shutter
added that and they also added um
several movies that were brought up in
the course of the documentary and like i
said the documentary takes like a deep
[ __ ] dive and it's not just the folk
horror that we're familiar with here in
the us maybe where it's kind of like uh
you know british folk horror like wicker
man or american folk or like
or maybe like children of the corn or
harvest home or something like that it
covers those but it covers stuff like
from all around the world and even does
some stuff about kind of like haitian
voodoo type films and that kind of stuff
so it's really uh comprehensive now
in that documentary uh they talked about
some australian uh folk horror films
uh you know a lot of which had to do
with kind of like indigenous beliefs and
stuff like that
in passing
they mentioned this one right here which
is sort of i guess yeah you could call
it a folk horror movie in the sense that
uh you know the antagonists are kind of
like remnants of or a modern day
celtic they kind of worship a celtic
goddess demon-ish kind of situation so
in the and there is kind of like a
stonehenge kind of thing going on in it
as well uh maybe kind of the same way as
halloween three gave me a little bit of
a vibe of that although to be honest
this reminded me quite a bit of
something like rosemary's baby um
although it's not as great as that but
you know it had that kind of like vibe
to it this movie is called allison's
birthday and as i said i had never heard
of this in my whole entire life um and
i've seen some australian horror
and uh you know so i'm not averse to it
or anything but it's just kind of like
this is one that sort of
came and went i guess it came out the
day after christmas in australia back in
1981
and i don't actually know
i think it was released in the us but i
think it was released as like part of a
series or part or like on a disc with a
bunch of other movies like a bunch of
other kind of like forgotten movies from
around the world or whatever and so
i thought it was kind of cool so i saw
that you know it was mentioned offhand i
said oh that sounds kind of cool even
though they didn't go a lot into what it
was about they just showed a couple
scenes from it and i said oh that looks
kind of cool like because i really like
late 70s early 80s kind of like creepy
sort of movies like this and so i i saw
the shutter added it so i was like oh
what the hell
so we'll watch it
now
i'm not gonna okay so one thing i will
say and i think the reason that i liked
this so much
was because as i said i'm really into
like that late 70s early 80s made for tv
horror type vibe if you grew up in that
era you kind of know what i'm talking
about even though some of them weren't
super scary they obviously because they
were made for tv they couldn't be real
gory or real graphic or anything like
that but a lot of them really had kind
of
something about them that really
resonated with me and really stuck with
me over the years and honestly like a
lot of great filmmakers like steven
spielberg probably most famously uh got
his start doing tv horror he did duel
and he also did one called something
evil i believe
that was also quite good and quite
creepy so i really like that kind of
vibe so i'm just gonna say if you like
tv movie type stuff from this era then
you'll probably really dig this now one
criticism that i will give it
and i know that a lot of people are
gonna have this criticism
it's very predictable like as soon as
you know the opening scene you have like
kind of a a prologue type thing and then
like as soon as the opening scene
happens and it starts starts building up
there's really no mystery as to like
what's gonna happen it did end not
differently than i thought but
they went it's and maybe this is a
spoiler but it did have like kind of a
more downer ending than i was expecting
uh so i actually kind of like that
because i feel like a lot of british and
australian movies will go for the downer
ending where american movies are usually
kind of like well that's like too much
of a bummer but uh yeah so it did have
that but
you're gonna be able to figure out
what's going on like almost immediately
so especially because you know movies
like this have been made you know tons
of movies like this have been made since
then so it's not going to be any
surprise but that said
if you really like these kind of just
creepy culti sort of uh films and you
haven't seen this one this is one is
definitely worth watching even though as
i said it's not going to be any surprise
uh so this was actually directed by a
guy named ian coughlin i guess is how
you pronounce coughlin or cochlin
not sure you pronounce it and um he
actually did mostly work in tv which is
probably why the movie comes across like
that and some of the funding was also
from uh australian television australian
film commission and fontana films and
stuff and some of the other uh like i
think an australian tv network now uh
most people will recognize the main girl
in this who plays allison is played by
joanne samuel who i believe was also in
mad max
the other actors a couple of them looked
kind of familiar but i couldn't like
place where i'd seen them before
um so the one thing i will say and i
think the best thing about this movie at
least for me because the story was kind
of like predictable like i said you
could pretty much you pretty much knew
where it was going but honestly the best
thing about it was the two leads like
the the guy and the girl allison and her
boyfriend pete
who's played by an actor named lou brown
those two were just really so you know
they weren't flashy or you know anything
like that but they were just kind of
like regular people and they were really
likable and they seemed really
uh you know their relationship seemed
very cool like very organic and i really
really liked the way they interacted
with each other and i really liked the
way uh lou brown in particular the
boyfriend character he was actually the
best character i think to me and i'll
get into that uh for in a minute but so
what you have you have sort of like a
prologue which takes place when alison
is only 16 years old it's the same
actress you know the actress is supposed
to play a 16 year old and then a 19 year
old even though she's clearly like in
her mid-20s but you know that's par for
the course they did that a lot back then
so at the beginning she's 16 and she's
at a house with her like two school
friends so they have their little school
uniforms on and everything like that her
school's her uh friends names are
chrissy and maureen and they are of
course playing with the ouija board
which you know if you do that in a
horror movie obviously like bad [ __ ] is
gonna end soon indeed that is what
happens uh in this situation so they
kind of start [ __ ] around with it
it's not actually a ouija board they
actually made it with uh it looked like
scrabble tiles and they had like a glass
in the middle
so what ends up happening is that
chrissy
one of the girls she seems to get
possessed by a spirit
who says that he is alison's dead father
and this spirit warns allison don't go
home for your 19th birthday or like bad
[ __ ] will happen it's like kind of says
creepy [ __ ] like that then there's all
kind of like paranormal hell breaks
loose the windows bust open [ __ ] starts
flying around and a bookcase then falls
on chrissy the girl that was possessed
and uh you find out later actually
killed her it does look like they killed
her and then like later on when she's
telling it to her boyfriend yeah she did
get killed
so then we jump ahead
uh you know three years
so it's
getting to be the time for alison to
turn 19
which obviously is something that the
ghost warned her about you know don't go
home for your 19th birthday it's like
this big thing and she's kind of been
thinking about it like all this time
presumably so she has moved to i think
is sydney i think that's where they shot
this and she's working in like a record
store and her boyfriend pete is a radio
dj like he works at a radio
so she is going to uh her and pete are
actually going to spend his birthday
together they're like looking forward to
it but then uh her aunt jenny calls from
wherever she it was she grew up or moved
from which i assume was someplace out in
the country
and says uh you know oh we you should
come home for your 19th birthday because
you know all the relatives are coming we
haven't seen you in a long time and you
know it would be really nice to see you
and we want to have a big party for you
and she's kind of just like nah i don't
really want to do that
but then because she's reluctant uh aunt
jenny says
oh well i didn't want to say this and
don't tell him i told you anything but
your uncle dean is like really really
sick like implying that he's dying and
it's like maybe this is the last time
you get to see him alive and all this
other kind of so she's like laying a
major guilt trip on
so allison's still kind of like me and i
really don't want to do this i kind of
wanted to stay here with my boyfriend
like we had plans and everything but at
last she's just kind of like okay fine i
will come home for a few days you guys
have a party it'll be fine
and again because she's reluctant uh her
boyfriend pete is like well do you want
me to like go with you and he's like
i'll at least drive you up there you
know what i mean and then he's like
because my dad kind of lives in that
area i can go visit my dad and then i
can pop over and see you so you know if
you have to get out of your family's
house so she's like yes thank you that
would be very nice
now you find out later like while
they're driving up so uh aunt jenny and
uncle dean were ostensibly like alison's
you know parents because she says oh my
parents died in a car accident when i
was a baby so i didn't know them and my
aunt and uncle like took over my care so
they've raised me my whole entire life
so you know i felt kind of bad
just like blowing them off even though i
didn't really want to go home
now interestingly uh so they get up to
the house well again while they're on
the drive and this is one thing that i
really liked about the pete the
boyfriend character
uh is that she basically tells him uh
you know she's like i really didn't want
to go home for my 19th birthday and
she's like this is gonna sound really
stupid but back when i was 16 uh we had
this seance thing like with the ouija
board and it seemed like my dead dad
told me hey don't go home for your 19th
birthday and i've been thinking about it
the whole time awesomely her boyfriend
does not laugh at her uh does not be
like that's the stupidest thing i've
ever heard which i think is one of the
reasons i like his character because he
really seems to like go against type but
in a way that doesn't make it seem like
it was deliberate he just seems like
he's being a regular dude and the fact
that it stood out to me and i'll get
into like more [ __ ] that he did later
that like really stood out to me i'm
like what a good character um it's
interesting because i guess the fact
that it stood out to me is sort of
indicative that a lot of horror movies
have this kind of trope where
a lot of times and it's usually female
characters not always where they're the
ones like experiencing something weird
or experiencing something paranormal and
they try to tell you know we talked
about this a little bit we talked about
like the show of haunting and everything
where you get a thing where it's like
the woman is the one seeing all the
ghosts and [ __ ] and then she'll try to
tell her husband and he'll be like
you're so you're hysterical you don't
know what you want so i feel like that's
like such a trope in horror movies that
seeing
a dude that was not like that really
like stood out to me and it didn't
really occur to him until after the
movie was over that i was just kind of
like
wow that was like really not a character
that you saw but like i said it didn't
seem like they were trying to
deliberately subvert
the you know the stereotype it just
seemed like that's kind of what the
character was like you know what i mean
um and i don't even know if they were
even into like subverting the
stereotypes back in 1981 so i just kind
of feel like it was just like a very
organic character so he doesn't laugh at
her or anything he's just kind of like
because she's like well do you believe
in that paranormal stuff and he's just
like well you know he's like we actually
did a series on the paranormal like on
his radio show and he's like and i saw
some [ __ ] or heard some [ __ ] on there
that i thought was like pretty weird and
that i couldn't explain so he's like i
don't really know you know it's like you
know i'm yeah i'm kind of skeptical but
he's like it could be so he's just very
like
matter-of-fact about it and like i said
he's not teasing her about it or
anything and you know so it's so it's
kind of cool like that so she gets
dropped off at her aunt and uncle's
house and pete uh drops her off he goes
off to he's like well i'm gonna be in
town you know i'm gonna go see my dad or
whatever
and then you know we can hang out
we can go to the beach or whatever
so she gets dropped off at her aunt and
uncle's house and immediately it seems
like the [ __ ] that aunt jenny said on
the phone about oh uncle dean is dying
and stuff doesn't really seem all that
legit i mean obviously he seems you know
they're older but he seems like pretty
spry
so uh aunt jenny immediately like cuts
this down she's just kind of like yeah i
mean he looks like really good now but
he doesn't know that i told you so don't
say anything about it and blah blah blah
he's trying to like pretend like he's
not dying or whatever obviously he's not
dying they just wanted to like get her
up there like i said this is kind of why
this movie is like very predictable
because you know as soon as she gets
there that some sketchy [ __ ] [ __ ] is
going on like these this aunt and uncle
want her for something uh wanted her to
come up there
and they're trying to get her to like
not leave and trying to get her to like
stay in the house with them and they're
usually trying to like guilt her into it
like oh i you know we haven't seen you
in years and it's like why do you want
to go off to the beach with your
boyfriend and we haven't seen you should
stay here and like it kind of works at
first but then after a while she's like
bro like back off you know what i mean
just like i'm a [ __ ] adult and it's
like why you trying to try to keep me in
the house and she gets like really
skeeved out by it
uh she also gets skeeved out by
there's this ever since she was a kid
she said there was this uh stuff in the
backyard like a gate or whatever and she
was never supposed to go back there and
the aunt and uncle always said oh it's
because it's all full of like snakes and
stuff you know because australia so
there's all kind of like poisonous what
have you back there and uh you know it's
all overgrown and blah blah and she's
just kind of like i think i'm going to
check out what the [ __ ] is back there
you know what i mean so she goes back
there and essentially finds like a mini
stonehenge
which she's like huh okay well that's a
little weird now she actually does tell
her uncle she's like what the [ __ ] why
is there like mini snowhenge back there
and the uncle is just like totally fine
he's just kind of like oh you know the
guy that used to have this house a long
time ago he was really into
folklore and all this other kind of
stuff so he built that back there
because he was like an amateur
astronomer and wanted to see if it
really worked and all this other kind of
stuff so i was like oh good save all
right even though everybody knows that
that's not why that [ __ ] is back there
now as i said as she uh continues like
staying in this house weirder and
weirder [ __ ] happens like she's sleeping
one night and this really really old
woman uh comes in a room in a wheelchair
and is like trying to touch her face and
stuff which kind of reminded me of like
the touch of satan actually have you
seen that movie it was on mystery
science theater but yeah it was just
kind of like that woman was like a witch
that was like 200 years old or something
but so this woman comes in there and
she's like what the [ __ ] and then like
you know the aunt is just kind of like
oh that's your great-grandmother you
never met her before she came here for
your birthday party and she's like okay
can you not have her like wheelie in
here in the room it's like really really
unsettling so there's that and then she
starts having a bunch of nightmares
about
essentially like cults so like i said
the nightmares that she has that's
pretty much what's gonna happen that's
why it's kind of not really a surprise
when it does happen um so as i said it's
not going to surprise anyone much like
in rosemary's baby there's just kind of
like this big cult and they sort of
worship this
goddess uh celtic goddess i guess i
don't know if it's real or not named
myrna
i think it's m-i-r-n-e
or m-i-r-n-a i'm not really sure and uh
so she like
goes from body to body you know what i
mean so it's like she's in one body and
then they have a ritual and they
transfer her to another one and blah
blah so that's kind of what's going on
again one of the best things about this
is that her boyfriend pete i mean jenny
or
allison rather is actually like pretty
like i said skeeved out so she's always
kind of like she doesn't i mean she's
grown up with her aunt and uncle her
whole life so i don't think she
legitimately like first
jumps to oh they're in a cult and they
want to use me as a vessel for their
for their evil goddess demon or whatever
but
uh you know but she does kind of be like
well let's spend as much time out of the
house as possible because they're
weirding me out and they're being really
like suffocating
but pete to his credit good old pete and
like i said i was watching this movie
going yeah you go guy all right
like he pretty much immediately because
he'll show up at the house and then you
know the aunt and uncle are like well we
want her to stay here and we really wish
that you wouldn't be around so much and
he's just kind of like nah bro that's
not
what's gonna happen and he's not like
real like [ __ ] aggressive about it
but he's just kind of like yeah i'm
gonna get to the [ __ ] bottom of this
and so he pretty much twigs on to the
fact that something really weird is
going on and he i mean he legit like
breaks into their house one night and is
trying to get her out of the house and
all this other stuff so um so he's
really like proactive he really knows
something's the matter uh and he legit
like you know goes to a friend of his
that's you know into the occult and
stuff and is like what the [ __ ] is going
on and like tells her the stuff that he
knows and they he tries to figure it out
and he's like investigating and like i
said he keeps showing up at the house
like you know and so
i really liked that character i really
liked that he wasn't
um you know and like i said it's it's a
pretty common trope in horror movies
where a lot of characters usually dudes
uh they don't really believe the
paranormal stuff until it's too late
this one i really liked that he seemed
really on the ball
um you know and he's like i need to get
you know my girlfriend out of here
because something really weird's going
on and he was you know willing to go
to go kind of the distance like i said
breaking and entering and all this other
stuff to figure out what the [ __ ] was
going on and try to get her the [ __ ] out
of there and i really really liked that
so honestly the best thing about that
was like was his character and like the
interaction with him and the girlfriend
because i really like that
again i kind of feel like may i and
maybe that's because i kind of feel like
maybe american horror movies in
particular they try to um
sort of like
increase the conflict so they always
kind of have conflicts between
uh you know a husband and wife character
or whatever like if or friends or
whatever so they always have so that's
like you know so they have that extra
thing it's like all this conflict going
on between the characters oh and then
they have to deal with the monster but
honestly sometimes it's kind of
refreshing to see something
where there's not conflict where the two
of them are actually genuinely in love
with each other they're not fighting uh
they seem to get along really well and
when one of them is in danger uh he
immediately like jumps to and he's like
yeah i'm gonna figure this [ __ ] out and
figure out what's going on so it was
like really really cool to see that and
like i said i think that was probably my
favorite thing about it and the fact
that i noticed it and that it stood out
so much
really kind of threw into stark relief i
guess how many
how many uh horror movies don't have
that like are not like that or like i
said go with more of like the conflict
character base and it's not always like
i said it's not always like boyfriend
girlfriend husband and wife sometimes
it's just like friends or brother and
sister or whatever they always have like
a conflict between them that
is another layer on top of whatever the
antagonist is that they're fighting so
it was kind of cool like to see
more like cooperation but yeah so
if you like sort of tv movies from this
era if you like kind of it this is kind
of like a folk horror in the sense that
i mean it's set in the modern day
obviously or in 1981 but it does have
like a kind of
you know stonehenge celtic cult type of
thing going on uh it's not overtly folk
horror but you could still it still has
folk horror aspects as i said its very
influence seems to be from like
rosemary's baby where all of these
people are coming in they're all kind of
like in on whatever this plot is and she
doesn't really know what's going on you
know they do things like drug her and
you know have a doctor in there that's
you know much like in rosemary's baby
that's you know in with the cult and
everything so they have all that kind of
going on
and then you have like one person it you
know in that sense it's not like
rosemary's baby because she does
actually have a boyfriend and you know
he has a friend too that's also like
into the occult and they're actually
like advocating on behalf of her and
trying to save her whereas rosemary's
baby i mean rosemary didn't really have
that she was kind of like by herself
which was scary
but i mean this is not there's no you
know nudity there's no blood there's no
you know there's some like spooky kind
of imagery which i really like so it is
very much like a tv movie
but that's not a knock against it though
because as i said i kind of like these
sort of low-key
you know sort of slow burn uh you know
tv movie-esque stuff from this era and
if you like that if that sounds like
that kind of yeah thing that you would
maybe vibe with then check this out
because i feel like i had never heard of
it and i'm i'm you know i'm not like the
world's biggest expert on horror movies
but i've if i haven't seen horror movies
i've at least like heard of ones but
this one i had actually never heard of
before so you know and shout out to like
that
folk horror documentary on shutter for
even just mentioning it so and then they
added it on shutter so i could watch it
and i was just kind of like well that
was that was a pretty good little movie
you know what i mean it's not as i said
it's not earth shattering you're going
to know pretty much exactly what's going
on like in the first 10 minutes but like
i said that it didn't bother me at all i
was you know i just enjoyed watching it
i enjoyed the characters and i just
thought it was like a cool little
australian uh horror flick so as i said
if that sounds pretty cool it's on a
shutter at the moment if you want to
check it out you might i'm sure you
could be able to stream it other places
too but i don't know where i watched it
on shutter but uh yeah it was pretty
good and definitely worth watching uh so
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
i will see you guys on the next one
bye